a digital signature is basically the the
mathematical mechanism for
essentially combining a public sequence
of numbers with a with a given digital
message and you can really think of
a digital signature in many ways as the
electronic analog of a physical
signature so in a physical signature
you'll typically affix let's say a
sequence of characters representing your
name or identity to a document okay and
this process effectively binds your
identity to that document
and more so by by formulating the
characters in your name and maybe some
particularly unique or peculiar way
that's unique to you the hope is that
nobody will be able to forge your name
on that document
now in a digital signature scheme it
turns out you can achieve these kinds of
properties mathematically now some of
the more well-known digital signature
schemes include things like the the rsa
digital signature scheme which stands
for their best shamira edelman scheme
there's also a scheme known as dss which
is the digital signature standard
actually
and actually if you were to use a scheme
like rsa or dss in my mind it's actually
a lot harder to forge these digital
signatures than it is to forge a
handwritten signature
so this particular video i'll try to
describe the overall
higher level mechanics if you will of a
digital signature scheme but i won't
actually go into or describe the the
underlying mathematical details of let's
say a specific scheme like rsa or dss at
least not in this video
so the way that a digital signature
scheme works is let's say you have a
user i'm going to call her alice and
let's say alice wants to
digitally sign a document
in the scheme in a digital signature
scheme alice is going to first generate
two keys and
these two keys are known as the
as the signing key the signing key which
is a private key so i'm going to use red
to denote it and we'll abbreviate the
signing key as sk
and then alice is also going to generate
a separate key known as a verification
key now the actual process of coming up
with the signing key and the
verification key it kind of happens
concurrently
alice will generate these two keys at
the same time and they're going to have
a mathematical relationship
okay but
the interesting thing is that you want
it to be the case that the verification
key is public and the signing key will
be private
but more so
in a digital signature scheme it should
be hard to come up with the verification
key
or rather it should be hard to come up
with a signing key rather if you only
see the verification key
okay
now let's let's consider what a digital
signature on a message will entail so
basically if you have a message and
let's call this message m
and you wish to digitally sign that
message what you're going to basically
do is apply a
mathematical transformation alice is
going to apply a mathematical
transformation uh to the message m
and her signing key sk
okay and the result of that
transformation
the output of the transformation will be
a special
uh sequence of numbers that we call the
the signature the signature
on the the message m okay
now the interesting thing here is that
the signature basically is
one that is derived from a combination
of the message m
together with the signing key the
private signing key of alice and it's
going to effectively
produce a short ideally relatively short
sequence of numbers as an output
okay and
in particular digital signature schemes
should be designed or they typically are
designed so that only the person who
possesses the signing key that private
signing key
is capable of generating this type of an
output this this type of a signature
s sub m on the message m
okay
now the verification process is kind of
analogous to the to the signing process
but it involves the public verification
key so in the verification process you
actually have three different inputs so
the first input will be the message that
you want to
to verify the signature of
you also need in addition to the message
you need to get as input the the
signature on that message what does that
s m look like and then finally
the input the final input to the
to the verification scheme will be the
the public key the public verification
key uh that belongs to alice okay
and these three inputs are put in and
there's a mathematical transformation
it's applied to these three inputs and
basically what that mathematical
transformation is trying to to ascertain
or to check is that the
the signature that you see corresponding
to the message m
is one that would have been produced by
alice's private signing key
and this private signing key in turn
corresponds to alice's public
verification key now what i think is
really remarkable is that
you can actually
carry out this process
with just the verification key that you
don't actually need
the the signing key to validate a
digital signature you don't even need it
inadvertently or indirectly you can do
everything you can verify everything
with knowledge of only
the public verification the verification
procedure basically outputs kind of a
yes or no it tells you should i
should i accept the signature or should
i should i reject it okay it's a basic
validation procedure
and so as you can see the the process of
signing effectively will bind
this public verification kid binds a
public verification key
to to alice somehow right because alice
is the one who published this
verification key and told the whole
world hey this is my verification key in
the system and only
i will be able to sign messages that
will be considered valid with respect to
that verification key
okay and because the the message is now
being essentially bound to this public
key
and if you think of the public key as an
identifier of sort maybe an identifier
for alice
then you can think of digital signing as
a process that basically binds an
identity to an underlying message and
that really gives us
in the mathematical sense it gives us
the analog
of a traditional handwritten signature
okay now i want to make two remarks and
i think that are particularly relevant
so first of all you'll notice that the
transformation that produces
the actual
digital signature itself
okay this transformation right here that
produces smm
this transformation basically takes the
message
it takes the message as one of its
inputs okay
and what that means is that the
signature is dependent on the message if
you change the message you'll get a
different signature now in this sense a
digital signature is actually different
from a traditional handwritten signature
okay your handwritten signature probably
doesn't change or more or less stays the
same regardless of what it is you're
signing but your digital signature is
very sensitive to what you're signing
and it will vary depending on what you
sign if you send a different message
you'll get a different signature as an
output
okay the second remark i want to make is
that
digital signatures are often associated
with uh cryptographic hash functions and
i've already done a video on
cryptographic hash functions and in fact
i mentioned in that video and i'll
reiterate here that the first
cryptographic hash functions were
actually designed
specifically with digital signatures in
mind is there as their killer
application if you will
so in particular what typically happens
that before you actually assign an
arbitrary message let's say you have a
huge message that you want to sign
before you sign this message you're
going to basically
apply
a cryptographic hash function to that
message and you're going to get
an output from that function that
cryptographic hash function you'll get a
shorter output the digest of that
cryptographic hash function and then
what you do in a signing algorithm is
rather than signing the original message
you will first hash it and then sign the
the hash of the message you'll sign the
resulting digest instead of the original
message
okay
and
this two-step paradigm of doing kind of
hashing and then signing really ends up
simplifying the process of digital
signing since you effectively are no
longer dealing with an arbitrary length
input but instead you're working with a
fixed length quantity
okay and this hash and sign paradigm
actually is safe
as long as it's hard to find
two messages that map to the same output
under the application of the hash
function in other words you can't come
up with with two messages
that are different but whose output when
the hash function is applied to them are
identical okay in other words
the hash function as long as it's
collision resistant
okay will result in a secure signature
scheme with this hash and sign paradigm
okay now you can probably think about
this for a moment but if you could find
let's say two input messages that are
distinct and that map to the same output
under an application of the hash
function
that would in fact lead to some bizarre
problems because
a signature on the first message
would then be identical to a signature
on second message since in both cases
what you're doing is you're not signing
the actual message you're signing the
hash of the message so if the hashes
are identical you'll end up with the
identical signature on two different
messages and that could create problems
like making it easy for maybe a
particular message to be forged
under this digital signature approach
and that's obviously something you don't
want you don't want
someone to be able to come up with a
signature on a on a different message as
opposed to maybe the one that you
initially
intended to sign
okay
now it is possible
and i just want to make this this clear
it's possible to describe
digital signatures with a lot more
mathematical formalism but my hope with
this video really was to give you a
flavor if you will without drilling into
all of the the underlying nuances in
mathematics